i feel like questions of whether or not
a
disney owned property actually delivered
on any kind of
lgbtq plus representation has has come
up before in the not so recent oh
oh boy
hey folks this is the other follow-up
that i wanted to do
on loki now that season one
has wrapped up this one's way less
spoilery
than the one i did back on wednesday
talking about
well implications of what happened in
the finale
i'm not gonna promise no spoilers on
this but spoilers are not the point
because i'm talking about something that
was revealed
a couple episodes in and was core to the
show and pretty much everyone knows
about at this point and that is
sylvie primarily and also lgbtq
representation in the show
in general did it promise us anything
ahead of time did it deliver
on those promises did it deliver
something else did it deliver at all
well let's take a look at this and this
is kind of important for me to do
because i unabashedly
loved loki i thought it was
excellent i was enjoying it all the way
up through the finale but i knew the
finale was really going to make her
break this thing
and i loved the finale so i really like
this show
but liking something is not a reason to
give it a pass
on issues that i care about and have
brought up before
and specifically brought up before in
regards to disney
so yeah let's take a look at this
first things first was there anything
that could be considered a promise
made ahead of time now this is actually
kind of important because this is part
of the pattern for disney
up to this point prior to the release of
the live action beauty and the beast
we were told by the director bill condon
that there would be
an exclusively gay moment for the
character of lefou
let's set aside the fact that the only
queer representation you felt like
putting in there was a character whose
name literally translates to
the fool and is the villain's henchman
and lackey but
also the supposed exclusively gay moment
is basically blinking you'll miss it not
a confirmation and anyone who wishes to
ignore it easily can do so
more recently we had solo a star wars
story
where one of the writers
said that there was a fluidity
to lando calrissian's sexuality
that would be evident in the film
and it wasn't it was kind of hinted at
that maybe he had a thing going with his
droid
except a i don't really buy it because
really the only direct source on that is
the droid herself
i'm sure you've noticed that lando has
feelings for me which makes working
together difficult because i do not feel
the same way about him
yes yeah yeah i see that and b
even if that is to be the case the droid
is distinctly coded
feminine so even there it's
it's arguably a species leap not
actually a gender leap in terms of any
kind of depiction of
pansexuality bisexuality or anything of
that nature
so again talked up ahead of time
did not deliver did loki
promise anything ahead of time it kind
of did
so in the lead up we got this
image and i actually talked about this
in a video over on the break room of
geeks
subscribe to that channel if you haven't
already but
this listing sex fluid
i took no a lot of people took note of
that
because this is something that up to
this point honestly disney had kind of
gotten a pass on
because sexual and gender fluidity
of loki is well first of all it's a
thing
tied to the character all the way back
to norse mythology
so it's not invented by sjws
secondly it has been an increasingly
core component to the character as
depicted in the comics
now the thing is nobody was really
holding
disney's feet to the fire over this up
until this point
because disney and marvel when they make
these into films or tv shows do not
bring in
every single thing from the comics they
don't have the time the space
nor the obligation to do so they cherry
pick what's going to work and they work
with that
so pretty much especially at this point
it's accepted that
they're going to present us with a
version of these characters
that will not necessarily include every
single aspect of it ever seen
would it have been nice to have seen a
queer or gender or sexual
fluidity to loki prior to the show well
yeah
absolutely i i at least speaking for
myself
not really speaking for the community
but i didn't see calls for it and i
certainly wasn't calling for them to do
that
so when i saw that image you'd think i
would get excited i didn't i got nervous
because i didn't have expectations
before
now i do now
you can disappoint me like you've done
before
repeatedly so
that brings us to the subject of
sylvie the female loki
variant so the question becomes
is this lgbtq plus representation
is loki depicted as a character as being
sexually or gender fluid
is sylvie a trans
character how exactly does this work
and unfortunately it kind of falls short
by that measure because at this point
what it appears to be is that
dossier was not specific to the loki
that we knew that was the main character
played by tom hiddleston
it appeared to be a bit more of a
dossier on loki's as a concept because
we saw
many variants of loki's and since the
time variance authority the tva had been
tracking down and trying to capture
sylvie a loki variant for some time and
they would have known
she was a woman when classifying loki's
as a whole
sex fluid meaning could be a number of
things was something that would make
sense
when looking at the big picture if not
necessarily a specific instance
because there's no indication of a fluid
sex or gender
to tom hiddleston's loki none whatsoever
we do have a confirmation of bisexuality
which i'll kind of pause the rest of
this and address really quickly
i thought that was done quite nicely
your prince must have been
would be princesses or perhaps another
prince
a bit of both i think normally i might
be a little bit more
critical of a
depiction and a confirmation of
someone's sexuality in a more
sort of casual just dropped in their
line something that could
easily be cut distributing it to foreign
markets like don't get me wrong i still
appreciate more
that more than nothing and normally i'd
be a little bit more critical of that
i'm not too much here
partially because loki is a character
while
exuding a lot of um well i don't mean to
sexualize a an actor i don't know but a
lot of sexual energy
in the performance didn't really have
romantic or sexual plot lines
so it didn't bother me so much that the
confirmation of
loki the one we know being bisexual
just getting this little line you know
quick exchange really just one line
confirming was more okay with that
because
that entire element of his character at
all hadn't really gotten screen time
anyway
so it's not like we'd gotten a ton of
time with him
talking about being with women or us
watching him be with women
and then this comparatively gets way
less attention
at the time it was said that's honestly
probably the most
attention loki's sexuality had gotten at
all
now you could make the argument that it
gets undermines somewhat given
what appears to be the romantic
entanglement between
him and sylvie i don't really want to
get into the weeds
on that i know um some people found it
unsettling or disturbing because even
though this is technically not
a blood relative and being a variant it
makes it weird and
but some people just get squished out by
self-cest
like it can feel weird and like ping
um emotions or triggers or just make you
feel like oh that doesn't seem right and
even though the narrative is constructed
in a way in that it's not
actually an incestuous act from a
technical definition like
i get why that bothers some people i
didn't like just because i don't like
romantic subplots for league characters
i almost never do so that was why i
didn't like it but
i do want to move on from that so coming
back
to sex fluid or gender fluid see i'm
going to say gender fluid because even
though the show
had it listed sex fluid sex fluid isn't
really a thing in real life not with
humans anyways there are other species
that
are actually able to change their sex
but gender fluidity
is a thing that exists amongst human
beings
hi gender fluidity is a thing sex
fluidity isn't
and so one could maybe try and make the
argument that
well no the show didn't actually promise
anything because what it listed the idea
of sex being fluid
that's not actually a thing so
did they really make a promise well they
kind of did
because while sex fluid
isn't a thing it is analogous
and linked to gender fluidity
which is a thing and the thing is even
going by sex fluid i don't really think
they delivered on that
they only delivered it from the one
perspective of looking at loki
as a as an event across all of these
varying timelines
but as an individual no
because i want to circle back onto
sylvie for a couple of reasons
first is she is the only female variant
we see
and there is active dialogue within the
show
to indicate that she may well be the
only female loki variant
have any of you met a woman variant of
us
sounds terrifying oh she is with that in
mind
one has to ask does that make her a
trans character
well as yet we have no confirmation of
that
might it get confirmed and or explored
in a second season
maybe i'm not going to give it a pass
though
because a bit like and i hate that i
keep coming back to this franchise
as a point of reference but it's helpful
regardless
much like when dumbledore
appeared in fantastic beasts 2 crimes of
grindelwald
the fact that jk rowling claims he's gay
was not in evidence in that film
and even before i completely wrote off
the harry potter franchise and its
creator
i did say like look it's possible that
they are going to deal with that again
later but i also said there's no way it
won't look like a correction because
there was no reason to not confirm it
here
if you were always planning to do it and
eventually actually address it why
wouldn't you address it at least
somewhat here where it first comes up
so that it looks like you know what
you're doing as opposed to
trying to fix a missed opportunity or
you were just dipping your toes going
are people going to be okay with that
and then waiting for confirmation before
going ahead and doing it
and it's a similar situation here if we
get into season two of loki
and we get a confirmation that silvi is
in fact a
trans character and i'll i'll
address to what extent she is or isn't
because right now it's actually still
open-ended i'll
come back to that but if we get a
confirmation next season that she
is i will appreciate that
but it won't fix the fact that it wasn't
confirmed in the first season when there
was no reason for it
to not be so it will still feel like
a correction or a retcon
or a they didn't have the nerve
to deliver the first time so ask the
question of whether or not sylvie is
trans first as i said it is noted that
she does appear to be the only female
variant
now that might
indicate transness because otherwise it
seems to be a bit of a one in a million
situation because there's all these
loki's and only one woman
wouldn't it almost be more likely that
loki is always male at
birth but then this loki
became female another thing that would
line up with that
is sylvie's rejection of the name loki
loki don't call me that
don't call me variant i'm sorry but i'm
not calling some
faded photocopy of me loki good because
that's not who i am anymore
i'm sylvie now she doesn't use the term
dead name but she does kind of react to
it in that manner it's coded that way
but at the same time even though i said
well you know
only one female in all these many that
seems odd
we also had an alligator that was a loki
although affair is fair they did at
least plant the possibility that it's
not actually a low key and who's to say
he's even a loki variant
he's green isn't he there's also the
line from sylvie where she says
the universe wants to break free so it
manifests chaos
like me being born the goddess of
mischief
now some have taken that to mean that
she was in fact
born female but it's important to keep
in mind that for
many trans people not all but many trans
people
they knew from a very early point in
their lives that
they were always the gender that they
are the gender that they transitioned to
so in the case of trans women
they always knew that they were a woman
and some will even say i was born a
woman
into the wrong body possibly but still
born a woman so that phrase itself does
not necessarily invalidate the
possibility that sylvie is
trans and was born male it
does however muddy the waters and it
feels like the show at this point in
terms of that question
has just decided to not commit it won't
pick a side and
draw a line and sand and go this is what
we're doing it seems to be riding the
line
and i feel like it knows it's doing that
because
that image of the dossier with the sex
fluid
i was dead certain when that first came
out that that was going to turn out to
be a marketing only image
and it was never going to appear in the
show but it did
which means somewhere in the course of
the show
these possibilities these options
occurred to somebody
but they decided to not deal with it yet
which does feel a bit like a broken
promise
it does feel like well look you brought
this up as a possibility
you decided to start exploring this and
you are the ones who have decided
to avoid the question of whether sylvie
was always female from a physical
biological standpoint or is in fact a
trans woman
and there was a point in my past where i
might have said
no you know what it's okay she's
interpretable as that i can work with
that
i'm not there anymore if she is i want
it said
and if she's not i don't want it hinted
that she might be
i want characters to be what they are
not be this weird middling
trying to appeal or be coded a way to
appeal to
lgbtq plus people but not confirmed so
that we don't alienate the mainstream
either do it or don't because the days
for
hinting the days for open-ended
interpretable representation they're
gone
we need to move past that
and i do feel a lot of ways that's what
sylvie is
right now is she is that what she was
intended to be
maybe not maybe in the writers room they
genuinely thought
from the beginning we will deal with
this in a second season and
part of what how we want to do that
story means it's better for us to reveal
it later maybe that's the conversation
that happened but i don't know
for all i know that is just as likely as
they sat down and went
oh you know that be a really interesting
thing but i'm not sure that people will
take to it let's
let's hint at it see what people say and
then maybe later we'll do it they're
equally as likely i can speculate all
day long but i can't know the minds
of the creators the writers i can only
express
my frustration now you may notice
given how i tend to address these kinds
of topics this isn't
a shouting frustration so this is hardly
the harshest i've ever been
to disney in particular but
i'm getting real tired of having
representation dangled in front of me
and either not delivered or delivered in
roundabout
deniable ways
give it if you're going to give a give
it and if you're not stop
i hope that they confirm sylvia's trans
next season
because i think that's a more
interesting story to tell
in terms of her life and what her
variance was
and it has the potential to speak to a
lot of trans people because a lot of us
feel that we are persecuted for being
who we actually are and
if the idea that a loki
was trans identified and started to live
as a woman and that
was their nexus event that was what made
them a variant
there's a lot of very potent
storytelling to be done
with that at its core that is analogous
and relatable
to real world trans and lgbtq plus
issues
and i hope that that is an opportunity
that is not left to die on the vine
but we'll see i'm a bit disappointed
but we will see what are your thoughts
on loki the show in terms of lgbtq plus
representation
sylvian specific did i expect too much
did they actually issue a promise do you
think i went too gentle on them
whatever your thoughts are politely
leave them down in the comments and
let's talk about it
like share subscribe all that helps me
out i have a patreon that is how i pay
my bills
any amount you are able to give me there
helps there's also youtube memberships
if you want to help me out that way
rewards for every tier of support but
even if you're not able to do that don't
sweat it because at the end of the day
what i want you to remember is that you
are beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh